Yura max highlights and is your host
Louise Houghton hello everyone welcome
to a packed show coming to you from here
by the Brandenburg Gate in Berlin let's
take a look at what's on the program
today
adventurous accommodation we visit
Europe's quirkiest hotels speedy stroll
our reporter takes a brand new walking
bike her spin and plastics competition
this year's comported eleganza features
the close of the starts now let me ask
you where do you look to stay when you
go away for the night a hotel with a
pool a campsite or something a bit out
of the ordinary well we set off to find
Europe's most quirky hotels and came
across a room in a harbour crane on a
sea fort and even in a silver mine in
fact all of the five hotels we found are
pretty unbelievable but you need to have
a deep pocket if you want to spend the
night the fur Alda Crane Hotel in the
port of Amsterdam has to be one of
Europe's most unusual hotels it boasts
three high-end Suites located at a
height of 45 meters
the rooms features stylish furniture and
stunning views we didn't listen to this
hotel certainly isn't for people who are
afraid of heights it's built so you can
look all the way down from everywhere is
this high loss it makes me feel queasy
converting the old industrial crane into
a design hotel cost around 3 million
euros
how nice it costs 435 euros to spend a
night here
breakfasts not included the site's
absurd your Anna crane but in here you
forget the fact entirely because the
hotel rooms are so beautifully furnished
when darkness falls the scenery changes
making a stay here a truly unforgettable
experience from scaling heights to
plumbing depths Sweden is home to the
world's deepest underground hotel suite
it's situated 155 meters below ground in
a former silver mine northwest of
Stockholm it's a chilly minus two
degrees in the mine so it's just as well
the suite itself is heated Dennis and
Linda are impressed it shouldn't be
comfortable but it is in a strange way
people really call a call yeah not
stressed out just really really calm
yeah the hotel even offers room service
while a stay doesn't come cheap it
certainly is unique a hotel this hotel
this is something completely different
yeah even if you seen this from a pub
you have no idea what it's like down
here the mine suite brings hotel
accommodation to a whole new level
back above ground in the belgian town of
ghibli visitors can stay in a huge
wooden horse this is my kites a bit
macabre that you entered the horse
through the rear oh wow look how big it
is cool time to explore the second floor
here visitors find the dining and living
area as well as two more bags there's
also a balcony to step out onto and on
the third floor another surprise awaits
Denis and Nadine I'm going to sit up
here all night
the thing goes up no up and down I have
full control you don't find a Trojan
horse like this on every corner this
hotel lies in the middle of the sea spit
Bank fort was originally built to defend
the entrance to the harbor of Portsmouth
now it's a luxury island escape one's
arms and gunpowder were stored here but
now it's a place of hospitality where
guests can experience a night to
remember
oh my goodness look at that Wow you
wouldn't think it would be so big what's
in there are nine sweets here each one
is decorated in a different style
British entrepreneur Mike Clare bought
the fort in 2009 for some 1.3 million
euros he invested another 4 million
euros in converting the site into a
luxury retreat totally different from
anything I had expected and I don't
think we'd still have these some holes
there are flaws and all these little
sort of rooms I think it's marvellous
a bizarre construction in the Austrian
Alps from the front it resembles a bird
from the back it's more like a UFO and
that's how it got its name you Fogel
literally you bird in German
does look kind of like a bird
the compact hotel can accommodate up to
eight people and prides itself on making
guests feel comfortable and most of all
at home the windows make it bright it's
cozy and there is underfloor heating but
Simon prefers to get a proper fire going
this is great I was referred back well
today was really relaxing there was a
lot to discover in the house the night
will be great too I think I'll sleep
well here the perfect place for nature
fans who like their comforts if you
wanted to get around town quickly but
without using a car which mode of
transport would you choose a bike or
scooter maybe well there is a new
invention in production and it sparks
tons of interest around the world
already it's called a low pee fit and
it's basically a treadmill on wheels it
also goes faster than most other
vehicles in the cycle lane so I'll
report at mica krueger went to check it
out this is me taking a relaxing stroll
in each station I'm not at all in a
hurry but I'm still powering ahead
if you bought from your treadmill in a
boring fitness studio why don't you take
it out I picked up my local fit walking
bike a few hours earlier klopf annoyin
works for the manufacturer and showed me
how it functions before I set out on my
maiden voyage treading sets the bike in
motion but you assisted by an electric
motor why don't you just go out and take
a walk this is a bike we go faster it's
25 kilometres in an hour so you get more
distance with the lobby fit it's more
interesting like normal walking the bike
first hit the streets in 2014 and now
it's taking off internationally with a
growing ridership in Europe the US and
South America an American skateboarder
and TV personality posted a video of the
bike on his Facebook page it's been
viewed over 18 million times since then
it's become a runaway success even in
Qatar perhaps because regular cycling
can be difficult in a rope but with a
low before anything goes the Dutch
manufacturer is finding it hard to meet
demand
yes we have some problems while we start
producing at this moment so we were not
ready to sell it that was the reason
that yeah we we get a lot of requests
but you're still producing well if
everyone else can do it so can i right
sorry they found that 30 percent get
into gear immediately while Santos and
have major difficulties getting off to a
smooth start I was a 60% who need a few
minutes after practice
as it's different than I thought a lot
faster so I've learned a full day tour
of the city you don't need a license to
drive a low fever and helmets are not
mandatory
while practicing on a country roads I
find I can stop walking and still keep
moving then it's back to the city
I want to try out my newly-acquired
riding skills in downtown interests
the Dutch are known as a nation of
cyclists but they clearly not used to
sing in lobe effect on the street so I
by myself turning quite a few hats
after a while I really gets the hang of
it but I'm still drawing attention I
over take most cyclists with ease
although I'm hardly making an effort at
all then a few brave souls asked if they
can have a go zhuge zhengwo it's not
dangerous interest rose I let more
people have a go even women in higher
locals and tourists alike are keen to
jump on board it's more difficult than I
thought it's a little bit complicated
yeah it takes some practice but I
certainly wouldn't be able to enjoy my
ice cream as much on a normal bike
this was possibly the fastest and in the
same time the most comfortable walk of
my life it was really big
still even with all the interest its
awakened it's hard to imagine the lobby
fit replacing that enduringly popular
bicycle on the streets of the
Netherlands now when it comes to insects
there are a few who know them as
intricately as leave on bits that is
because the British photographer has
been creating giant sized images of
these tiny creatures to make them beasts
honed a microscopic photographic
technique and the resulting images are
now on display in Oxford England if the
visitors are as fascinated at each tiny
detail as bases then maybe the public
will put aside the negative thoughts on
insects and begin to see these creatures
in a whole new light this is not gold
foil
it's the wing of a South American be
magnified 300 times
and although this might look like a leaf
it's actually the armor of a tropical
tree hopper insects as we've never seen
them before each with its own surface
structure these images were taken by
Levon Biss he spent two years
photographing the insects and during
that time he developed a lot of respect
for them that surprises me how
complicated these creatures are and at
the same time how beautiful they are we
have this cliched idea of the creepy
crawlies being horrible or scary and you
know they're just not you know I don't
think there's one single scary picture
in this exhibition this named his
exhibition micro sculpture it opened on
May 27th at the Oxford University Museum
of Natural History
the museum has Britain's second largest
insect collection and this was given
access to its archives entomologist
James Hogan worked with Levon Biss to
help him find especially beautiful
examples we wanted to have specimens
that were not too big because in general
a lot of large insects have been
photographed before and people are quite
familiar with those kind of images so
the specimens were based on things that
I knew had an interesting surface detail
and would be interesting colors so
there's some insects there we have
really spectacular metallic colors for
example which I knew would look amazing
you know often leave on a photograph
them leave on Biss took the insects to
his studio in Wiltshire where he began
to experiment with micro photography
before that he was a professional
advertising and sports photographer a
whole different world the insect project
made him rethink how he works if you
think about it you know an eye the dome
structure of an insect is a very
different shape and texture and contours
to a leg which could be hairiness and so
the way I work is I treat every simple
single section like a small still life
and each section has its own bespoke
light and technique to make that one
particular section because as beautiful
as it possibly can
levon bisque combined 9000 individual
photos to produce the picture of the
jewel beetle under the microscope he
moved the insect 10 micrometers at a
time a seventh of the width of a hair it
took in three days to take the series of
pictures a sterile workplace was top
priority
you know the tiniest amount of of dust
on these creatures comes up huge in the
pictures so you have to have quite a
sterile environment and they have to be
cleaned properly before when the
photographer put the pictures together
on a computer working with this complex
jigsaw puzzle paid off he was able to
create incredible close-ups each hair of
the beetle can be clearly distinguished
Levon byssus photos show the structure
of the beetles body and let us explore a
new world insects are around us all the
time you see them all the time but you
don't really see them it's only when you
go all the way in that you can
understand how amazing how beautiful
these thick creatures are
to enable this close-up view the
pictures were printed as posters up to 3
meters in length special printers from
London were used to handle the huge
amount of data back at Oxford's Museum
of Natural History the photographer and
the entomologist both hope the show will
get people interested in these insects
I want to have a newfound respect for
these creatures to look at them in
amazement you know be astonished by them
and you know fall in love with them
I hope that it will encourage people to
study insects as well not just
appreciate them but you know to study
them because they're just fabulous
winning micro sculpture will be on show
in Oxford through August after that the
exhibition goes on a world tour so that
people in other countries can also view
the insects with new eyes time now for a
look at the architectural form known as
Brutalism this was the name given to raw
concrete block buildings and brutal is
how some saw this design plain grey old
and ugly but there are others who view
it as cool urban and a perfect backdrop
for advertisements
can plain rough concrete be sexy it
certainly figures a lot these days in
fashion adds massive geometrical forms
in gray can be dramatic
though the term sounds scary Brutalism
is in again brutalist architecture
emerged in the 1950s and survived into
the 1970s it always met with mixed
reviews distinctiveness that provokes
both love and hatred indifference is not
an option regards in say on me moths
Robin Hood Gardens is a London housing
estate designed by Allison and Peter
Smithson it was completed in 1972 today
many of the flats in the run-down
complex stand empty there are
redevelopment plans but the authorities
say the estate does not merit listing as
a Heritage Site architect Karl Shara
says that's a good thing so the people
over here suffered from a lack of
investment and maintenance of the
building but also the building itself
created a lot of the problems that could
have been resolved with better design
demolishing it now will provide a spur
an opportunity to continue the ideas
that created this building in the first
place famous architects including zaha
hadid and richard rogers campaign to
save the complex and many residents have
fought as well the arguments are
aesthetic social and political the
estate was a valuable example of public
sector housing with gardens and
community building facilities the pro
preservation campaign lost but triggered
a lively debate
what has happened as people have
realized that it doesn't mean it's
architecture that is is brutal but it's
architecture that's really honest about
its use of materials that it's
incredibly sculptural that it relates to
quite a lot of the art of the same
period and thus it's our architecture
that really wants to be kind of
imaginative and different London was
once a hotbed of Brutalism this is the
Royal National Theatre but fruit ilysm
was an international phenomenon the
aesthetics were radical and the social
agenda was too many of the buildings
have not aged well but if they're well
maintained and in a good location they
can be good places to live and the
Barbican estates here in the center of
London is a real example of how
brutalist architecture can work I mean
that's the private estate flats there
are very very expensive and people who
live there are incredibly enthusiastic
about it there is an online
international community of Brutalism
lovers the SOS Brutalism website posts a
growing database of buildings
the German architecture Museum in
Frankfurt is planning an exhibition in
Britain the Brutalism appreciation
society has 40 thousand followers on
Facebook bloggers in the US are also
singing the praises of the genre as a
script that supposedly Ralph knocks on
card it is easy to find it cool there is
a lot of positive chatter on the web
it's cold it is big and raw it speaks to
our instance perhaps to our baser
instincts Photography is after all
brutal it is one thing to be popular on
the Internet and another to be
acknowledged and appreciated by society
understood Stanley Kubrick's certainly
appreciated it as a dystopian nightmare
landscape in his 1971 film a Clockwork
Orange that could be considered a
contemporary critique nowadays brutalist
architecture has been tamed and
harnessed by old Couture its buildings
now figure as decoration on consumer
goods has a once bold vision decayed
into a lifestyle motif it becomes like a
black-and-white poster that you hang on
the wall and to show that you have good
taste but you have no connection to the
ideas and the philosophy that brought it
around and I think this is something
what a serious cultural shift that we
need to oppose admirers say brutalist
architecture deserves to be taken
seriously many hope the major show at
the German architecture Museum next year
quite helped to set the record straight
while talking of shows we finish off
today with the most glamorous show of
classic cars the Concours d'Elegance a--
it takes place each year at Lake Como
and has been running since 1929 and for
those who don't know it is the place to
be if you love classic cars movie stars
and a good old competition magnificent
cars from every era of motoring and
their proud owners
that's the concours d'elegance a-- a
kind of beauty pageant for automobiles
the event took place at Villa testet on
Lake Como one of the highlights this
year was the competition category cars
of the stars here vintage cars that once
belonged to movie stars vie for top
place like this ferrari 275 gtb this car
was delivered new in 1967 to Steve
McQueen the Hollywood legend it was
painted at the factory in a standard
factory color called not Yola which is a
hazelnut gold color which when steve saw
the cuy hated it so his preferred paint
shop at the time mixed a color dubbed
Chianti rad which was approved by Steve
McQueen had the sports car with a 300
horsepower engine kitted out according
to his taste
for instance aluminum spoke wheels and
he also transferred this unique but
quite useless rear view wing mirror he
was a one-off and he liked one offs he
liked things that were unique special
and the car was offered by RM Auctions
in Monterey California
two years ago we we bid on the car and
were lucky to be successful and brought
it to the UK this unique car costs on
twelve million euros a ferrari 275 gtb
is never cheap since only 280 were ever
made but the fact that Steve McQueen
once on this one raised its price to
four times what others usually cost it's
not nice to be out on the open road in
the McQueen for camp unfortunately we
won't be able to drive it quite as hard
as he used to drive it around California
the jury at the Concours d'Elegance a--
aren't impressed that an automobile was
once owned by a celebrity that doesn't
pertain to the judgment we got the cars
not to the history of teach cars
this is Marcello Mastroianni I don't
know it's difficult to say we feel is
more important than the other
this 1966 Ferrari 330 was once the
favorite car of Italian film legend
marchello Mastriani right next to it is
a Jaguar xk120 from 1952 it belonged to
American actor Clark Gable the king of
Hollywood some were motor sports
enthusiasts like Steve McQueen car gable
was more of an old-school Hollywood star
glamour was important had to be a little
sporty yet still suitable for the red
carpet each year the International Jet
Set meets at the Concours d'Elegance a--
Clark Gable would certainly feel at home
here but in the end the jury picked
another car
McQueen's Ferrari 275 gtb would Steve
have felt at home here too
oh absolutely absolutely who wouldn't
they wouldn't by the side of Lake Como
the beautiful Villa d'Este Hotel
surrounded by petrol heads and some of
the most beautiful cars ever produced
this year's concours d'elegance a--
benefited from a bit of Hollywood
celebrity and the cars on display were
just as glamorous as the films of
Hollywood's golden era
well that glamorous notice brought us to
the end of the show for today thanks for
tuning in and until next week take care
bye bye for now
you